I want to start with a sincere
congratulations
um you are what's called fantastic in
this role thank you um and I'm curious
this uh I can't imagine what it was like
reading the script for you for the first
time because not only do you get to be
funny and you get to kick a ridiculous
amount of ass you also get to be
emotional it's like everything that you
would want I would imagine as an actor
what was it like actually for you
reading the script and seeing what Ryan
wanted you to do uh you know Ryan
actually talks you through it first and
then you get the script much later so I
was able to really think about a lot of
what he told me before and then yes then
then the script came later and yeah it
was it was no small task it was like
okay this is amazing and I but this is
also a uh you know it's a lot it's a lot
to accomplish and so definitely wanted
to
um the whole goal of this movie was to
honor Chadwick and and that was the
really at the core of why we came back
together
um after we lost him was about honoring
him through the Legacy he he started and
so
um yeah and knowing with it with him as
an anchor and the memory of him is such
an anchor it was just a knowing that you
know watching him work the last time and
how much he gave of himself at all times
you just you know there's no that you
know you go into this giving your all as
well and then that's that's how you
honor him I think Ryan does such a
phenomenal job on both of these movies
what is he like on set when he's giving
you direction does he pull you aside and
give you like a few words is he giving
you a lot of sentences what is he like
when he's asking you to do something
um yeah he definitely he does he does
some pool of sides he he you know he'll
come and talk to you he'll come to talk
to you or he'll pull you a little to the
side and he's uh he's very
um he's he's um he's very collaborative
but he's also very you know he's when he
can see something he's he's telling you
to try it this way or try it that way
and and um or he's you know changing up
a line with you and uh you know it's
it's very much about uh he's really in
it with you like he likes to he you know
on the day is very much of that moment
in the process where he's he's very much
like doing that that real we're really
cooking it is on the day on the set and
that's where he's like you know and I
deal with spark times you there are
things that can shift in in what you
have done over several takes that will
that could shift in the next take
because something's clicked and that's
exciting uh I can't even imagine
um I have heard that there's a Untitled
wakanda series being developed Nate has
talked about it
um I'm just curious what you might know
about that series what does Nate said
native said that this movie took up a
lot of time and they're not as far along
on that as something I'm paraphrasing
but perhaps maybe you know more oh well
I'm not gonna say more than Nate says I
mean what do you think I am crazy I'll
ask you a different question um you've
done you've worked on many different
projects and I'm always fascinated what
do you think was the hardest shot that
you've had in your career in terms of
whether it be because of camera moves
emotional performance what's a shot that
you will always remember as being oh my
God
uh wow uh a shot do you mean a scene or
literally like I mean a shot or a scene
whatever you'd like to share if you
don't mind
oh God I mean there's so many different
moments but I will say
there was this time that I was shooting
reshoots for black panther at the same
time as shooting Walking Dead so because
they both shoot in Atlanta they're like
ah you could just come here and then go
there so I was exhausted and um I had
there was something I had to do for
Black Panther in the reshoots that and I
had been doing like I've been um
I had been I had like three hours of
sleep between Okoye and Michonne and
then I came in and at the end of the day
of shooting I had to get in the harness
and like do this thing in the first
movie I think there's a moment that you
see where she's thrown off of a car and
she has to catch her Spear and and clamp
down to get onto the road I don't know
if you remember that I in in Korea in
the Korea sequence and I had I was in a
harness and I had to like do these like
flip myself you have to I have to use my
own momentum and flip myself and then
catch my spear which they had hanging
somehow over my head and it was just I I
just my body and my brain were just not
even interested they were like look
we're done like you're crazy we're out
and so it took a lot of tanks and then
um because I just couldn't get it I
couldn't get the coordination together I
was just so exhausted and then
um somehow in the last when Ryan was
like maybe we just need this price like
no I could do this I did it on Saturday
and so I I got I finally finally somehow
clicked it and I did uh two two takes
that really got it and uh was able to to
to to get it done for my character but
um yeah that was um just because of the
the level of exhaustion and the
Precision of the movement at the same
time it was not the easiest day thank
you for sharing and congrats on the
movie it's really so well done thank you